découvrez-en icinéma colossal a aucun
souvenir de ce qu'on s'est dit cette
nuit monsieur encore donner en spectacle
c'est ça ta voix tu étais pas vraiment
en vacances
ça faisait un an que je cherche du
boulot que tu vivais avec ton copain
n'est que ça n'ait pas marché
tu es hors de contrôle oui donc j'ai
fais tes valises elles sont dans la
chambre des fauchés comme les blés tu as
décidé de revenir vivre ici tout rien
d'autre
[Musique]
t'as aucun souvenir ce phénomène sans
précédent à pitre par francis terrible
événement qui va changer le cours de
l'histoire
[Musique]
oui c'est un tic
ça me démange
mais quel est le monstre
il s'était planté faire des gestes
bizarres et ses patins
[Musique]
tu entrais un truc incroyable
il est en train de danser et il fait
quoi comme colin batch
[Musique]
mais c'était quoi et ça un hélicoptère
s'est écrasé dans avec le pilote à
l'intérieur
[Musique]
ils attendent tous
attention avec insistance elle c'est le
monstre colossal le 27 juillet au cinéma
siro service de vidéo à la demande
exclusivement chez